hello and welcome back to new rockstars
i'm jessica clements and i'm here to
break down jordan peel's nope giving you
so many big fun crazy miserable details
baby and just like and get out and us
this movie has some little missable
details to make the story eerie
disturbing and just downright
catastrophic plus i just want to make
sure we're all on the same page you know
as the horror fiend i am you know i had
to dig a little deeper put on my tin
foil hat and storm area 51 they can't
stop us all this past weekend was the
san diego comic con so we got so much
news for marvel and dc and what's going
on animation everything in general so
i'm gonna keep this brief i'm gonna keep
it quick i'm gonna keep it fast because
we all got a lot of stuff on our plate
this goes without saying i'm about to
spoil it if you haven't seen nope yet
that's on you go now go right now to the
theaters watch it twice with a notebook
like i did then come back let's unpack
this bad boy i do want to start with
saying jordan himself mentioned an
interview with variety that he wanted to
make a big summer blockbuster that you
can enjoy any way you want that really
hit me in the spot you know allowing the
viewers to make any theories and all the
theories they want so let's just keep
that in mind as i take you into this
crazy conspiracy theory timeline
the movie opens up with a quote from
name36 i will cast abominable filth upon
you make you vile and make you a
spectacle like most biblical verses this
can be up to interpretation but later
could be seen as a warning when the ufo
or uap relieves its garbage and excess
blood upon the haywood house leaving
coins and keys burrowed into the
banister steps a wheelchair upon the
roof a spectacle indeed also this scene
was just chef kiss i love blood blood
falling on a house the movie takes place
in agua dolce canyon a little more than
40 miles outside of los angeles at the
haywood ranch named after their great
great great grandfather aleister e
haywood who rode the horse in the first
moving picture though the jockey on the
horse is real alistair haywood was
created by jordan peele we actually
don't know the name of the black jockey
riding the horse just the horse's name
which isn't that crazy what we do know
is there's tons of moybridge films out
there of people riding horses but jordan
used this one specifically with the
black jockey the jockey's job originally
was to ride the horse at the right speed
along a track so it would trigger a
series of tripwires attached to cameras
which reminds me of how oj and lucky
were speeding alongside the ranch fence
as the wacky waving inflatable arm
feeling two men were just shutting down
wacky waving inflatable arm flailing two
men
wacky waving inflatable arm flailing too
mad at the beginning emerald messes up
on her speech noting only two greats
when referring to her grandfather i
suspect this is because later on in the
movie when she's re-watching her dad's
video where he says word for word the
same thing she did emerald memorized and
recites her dad's version where aleister
haywood is his great great grandfather
whereas he'd be emerald's great great
great grandfather it's not a complete
mess up just you know she's great at
memorizing it's kiki palmer uh the ranch
is a hop skip jump away from jupiter's
claim founded by child actor ricky duke
park played by steven yen jupiter's
claim is already a website for you to
check out once you enter the cherry site
welcome by jupe it becomes eerie dark
and gloomy the sounds of the ufo can be
heard blasting your eardrums you can
also visit jupiter's claim on the
universal studio tour oj has been
selling horses to ricky to keep the
ranch afloat since his father passed
away six months ago ricky is a
formidable character in the movie though
his stay is sort of short-lived and
don't think i didn't notice those right
pair of scissors right there on his desk
just like the ones in us just silver
ricky was star of the fleeting 90 sitcom
gordy's home where he acted alongside a
real chimpanzee who one day goes literal
ape [ __ ] and attacks the actors eating
their face and smashing their skulls in
6 minutes and 13 seconds when describing
the incident to emerald comparing it to
the snl sketch mocking it there's no
actual snl sketch based on gordy but a
very similar sketch i'm sure they are
speaking of the mr peepers and papa
peeper sketch where kris katan plays a
human ape with violent behaviors papa
peepers is played by dwayne johnson so
by proxy dwayne the rock johnson has
made two indirect appearances in nope if
this chimpanzee attack sounds familiar
remember in february of 2009 charlotte
nash was mauled and attacked by travis
the chimpanzee who was also an animal
actor there's a lot to this story but
charlotte revealed her face to the
public for the first time after the
incident on the oprah winfrey show
wearing something identical to mary jo
elliott at the star lasso experience
it's mentioned and compared throughout
the movie that extraterrestrial is in
fact no different than a wild animal oj
saying is territorial it thinks that
this is his home jup's first mistake was
thinking he could tame a predator and
all the allegory director hulse was
watching was different predatory animals
in the wild attacking or being attacked
a number of animals recognize staring
into their eyes as asserting dominance
or inducing stress the more social they
are the less likely they are to take eye
contact as a sign of aggression it's
found in chimps that if you make direct
eye contact but if you aren't closely
bonded it could upset them to the point
of violence so make sure all those fist
bumps pay off
angel torrez played by brandon perea
refers to ufos as uaps in 2022 the
pentagon released a statement that they
were investigating what is now referred
to as uap's aka unexplained aerial
phenomena they created this program as
early as 2017. when talking to angel oj
references the navy clip he watched on
youtube that was declassified referring
to the footage from the usg that was a
fuzzy you couldn't really make it out in
2021 the pentagon officially
declassified and released said footage
it can be said that angel knows a lot
about aliens learning about them via
ancient aliens which is a long-running
documentary on the history channel with
over 212 episodes spanning across 18
seasons so no i did not watch it and i
do not plan to what kind of california
would i be not to shout out california
references the first one fry's
electronics fun fact this was my
electronics store in burbank might each
fry's electronics had a different theme
and this one mine was alien invasion it
had a giant octopus army men giant ants
it was phenomenal unfortunately fry's
completely shut down all locations in
2021 you can't see the eighth wonder of
the world like i did but if you did
kudos it's great and you can see it in
the film in the arena for the star lasso
experience we see banners for old town
new hall the historic core of santa
clarita and vazquez rocks a nature
center and park in santa clarita which i
also had just been told by daschler
cameraman my best friend but this is
also where they shot a lot of the star
trek scenes including when captain kirk
and goran fight
corn wedding the haywood home has
beautiful movie posters to films
including sydney podies and harry
belafonte's buck in the preacher jordan
peel mentions it was the first film that
he knew of that had black cowboys
represented in it he goes on to say the
film shares a spirit we also get a great
there here
poltergeist reference from angel when
the alien arrives i also don't want to
shy away from the impeccable clothing it
was referenced a ton o.j donned a
scorpion king 2001 crew hoodie where he
worked his first gig to end up using
camels instead of horses you know what
they say save a horse ride a campbell
the jesus lizard shirt that kiki palmer
is wearing is of a chicago noise rock
band with not much homage to aliens but
if we want to get conspiracy e america
being secretly ruled by a race of
extraterrestrial lizard people is a
popular theory and right on the nose i
am the lizard queen
angel's wearing a do metal group earth
shirt another fun fact i've seen this
shirt so many times and was racking my
head about it this is a metal band from
my hometown very popular go olympia
copperpox cove is where they dined upon
some sweet sweet fish sandwiches they
also dined on it and us jordan peel
loves fish sandwiches he even got a chef
on this set to make them fish sandwiches
we have a phenomenal mix tape on our
hands here we got a horribly spooky
slowed down mix of corey heart
sunglasses at night people gave us the
same thing and i got five on it for us
but sunglasses at night is certainly a
reminder to not make eye contact even in
the dark in an interview with ap jordan
peel mentions he was inspired by
jurassic park and king kong that really
deal with the human addiction to
spectacle which is probably why this
feels like a love letter to steven
spielberg it's giving joss being hunted
this time from above serving jurassic
park but don't look it in the eyes along
with this being a sick summer hit it's
following the same suit as spielberg
don't think i missed that sick okra
slide emerald had when entering
jupiter's claim speeding away from the
alien if you don't know the 1988 hit
acura please go watch it it's sick
futuristic with cool telepathic teens
corrupt government telekinesis it's just
an awesome flick who jordan peele is a
super huge fan of and was offered to
direct and said no it's a long story but
he basically said no because he was like
i'm looking for something different and
i don't want to do it wrong because he's
a godly man now this
is when i went mad this is when i went a
little insane i went a little crazy i
don't know what it means yet but sixes
are pretty big deals in this movie top
of the show we see name 36 it took six
minutes and 13 seconds for the chimp to
finish attacking six months since the
alien first arrived at 6 13 pm the alien
showed up to feed i know it means
something which is why i think it could
possibly connect to genesis 6 in the
bible now again a lot of scripture is up
to interpretation but genesis 6 is about
the nephilim translated to giants or
fallen ones the alien does share some
likeness to the accurate depictions of
angels some have also claimed that these
nephilim could technically be aliens
that came to earth but i could be
reading too much into this i recognize
that but it's worth pondering that's
just some of the things i've spotted
theorized let me know what yours are in
the comments below follow me on
instagram and twitter at lulu clemens
follow new rockstars subscribe and hit
that notification bell thanks for
watching now let's go watch signs
[Music]
you